I want to do one more video on total
revenue and price elasticity of demand
just to make sure that you the
relationship between the two is an
intuitive one so let's draw an arbitrary
demand curve so this is my price axis
price axis that is my quantity demanded
axis quantity axis and let me just draw
an arbitrary demand curve right over
here so let's say that is my demand
curve and let's pick some price and
quantities on this demand curve so let's
say that the price is up here let's call
that p1 and then the quantity demanded
let's call that let's call that q1 let's
call that q1 and we already know that
the total revenue is the area of the of
this rectangle right over here this is
the total revenue it's just the price
times the quantity if I'm telling if I'm
selling two burgers an hour and for nine
dollars a burger I'm going to make $18
per hour that's going to be this area
right over here now let's assume let's
assume in this part of the curve that
that the price elasticity of demand is
greater than 1 so we are elastic so let
me write this so the price the
elasticity of demand actually I should
say the absolute value of the elasticity
of demand it will be actually a negative
number but the absolute value of the
elasticity of demand is greater than 1
which means for a for a 1 percent 1
percent drop in price drop in price you
have more you have a greater than
greater than 1 percent increase increase
in quantity in quantity and that comes
straight out of the expression or our
formula for what elasticity is remember
elasticity is our percent change change
in quantity over a percent change change
in price so if this that if the absolute
value of this is greater than 1 these
move in opposite directions that's why
it would be negative but if we say the
absolute value of this is greater than 1
that means that this quantity is going
to be larger than this quantity so if we
have a 1% drop in price this the change
in our quantity is going to be greater
than 1% and so at for this point right
over here if we lower this by 1% we're
going to increase this buy more we're
going to increase this by more than 1%
so any drop in our any reduction in our
height will be more than made up for and
this is generally the case will be more
than made up for by an increase in our
width so total revenue will increase so
when price drops so 1% drop in price
would a larger than 1% increase in
quantity means that total revenue total
revenue will go up now if we go down
here if we go down to this part of the
curve and let's say that this let's call
this let's call that p2 and let's call
that quantity to quantity 2 and then
this area right over here would be total
revenue to total revenue 2 let's call
that total revenue 1 over their price
times the quantity now what's happening
over here we're going to assume that our
elast are price elasticity of demand the
absolute value of it over here is less
than 1 so the absolute value of our
price elasticity of demand is less than
1 at this point in the curve and all
that is is a fancy way of saying that
for 1% drop drew 1 percent drop in price
1 percent drop in price we get less than
a 1% drop 1 less than a 1% drop sorry
what less than a 1% increase they move
in opposite directions 1 percent
increase increase in quantity so we're
lowering the height if we if we have a
1% drop we're lowering that by 1 percent
but we're not getting a 1 percent
increase in our width so the width isn't
going to be increasing that much so in
general this is going to result in a
lowering of this area this area will get
smaller we're reducing our height more
than we are expanding our width so in
this situation in this situation total
revenue
total revenue would go down and remember
this is an elastic situation so when it
is elastic total revenue tends to go up
and when it is inelastic in a lot I want
to say when it's elastic a price a drop
in price tends to make total revenue go
up and when it is inelastic in elastic a
drop in price tends to make total
revenue go down and then you could
imagine right when you're at unit
elasticity someplace around there a 1%
drop in price will result in a exactly a
1% increase in quantity demanded and so
they will kind of trade off you won't
get a you won't get a noticeable change
you won't get a noticeable change in
your revenue and the reason why I say
that the reason why I say that is that
actually some many econ textbooks will
tell you that you don't get a change in
revenue but if you actually will do a
detailed look at the mats let me write
it over here so the absolute value of
the price elasticity of demand at that
point is 1 which tells us that a 1% 1%
drop in price will or it goes along with
a 1% increase in quantity but if you
look at the math so if the old area so
let's call this let's call this price 3
and let's call this quantity 3 right
over here and so total revenue 3 total
revenue 3 let me do some new color which
is this area right over there is going
to be equal to price 3 times quantity 3
now if we increase price by or if we
decrease price by 1% then this will
become 0.99 times our price and if we
increase our quantity by 1% then this
will become one point zero one times our
quantity now let's think about what this
number right over here is this is why
I'm saying it's not exactly the total
revenues are going to be exactly
unchanged if you multiply 0.99 0.99
times one point zero one you don't get
exactly one you don't get exactly one
another way to think about it
point nine nine times point OH
one is going to be 1% less than point
1.0 1 and 1% of 1.0 1 is slightly larger
than 1 or another way to think about it
this value is going to be one percent
larger than 0.99 and one percent larger
than 1% of 0.99 is less than 1 so it's
not going to get you to one and you can
see it with your calculator 0.99 times
one point zero one get you two very
close to one so this is going to be
equal to this is going to be equal to
zero point nine nine nine nine times p3
q3 which is equal to zero point nine
nine nine nine times total revenue three
times total revenue three but it is
total revenue three but it is roughly
roughly it roughly unchanged so we can
that's kind of the general rule of thumb
so when you are at unit elasticity unit
eel s tested unit elasticity then a
decrease in price roughly roughly says
no change no approximately no change in
total revenue so I just wanted to make
sure that it makes sense it really just
comes from these areas if you're
reducing the height by less than you're
increasing the width obviously the area
is going to increase if you or most of
the cases I should say it depends on
where you are if you are if you're kind
of compensating it whatever you reduce
the height you are compensating
perfectly with the increase in width
then you're not going to have a change
in revenue and if you decrease the the
height by more if you're taking more
area from the top then you're adding on
the width then you're going to have a
total decrease in total revenue